con primera diciembre de 1989 ingresé al
instituto antártico a trabajar con
personas de planta
la cual
justo me tocó trabajar en la logística
el primer día que ingresé un jefe me
dijo tienes que apoyar a logísticas
varias prendas cómo se trabaja como
siempre para una expedición que se llama
ica ica que significa la expresión
expedición antártica chilena
y para mí es un sueño estar el instituto
representando a chile en la expedición
la cual me puso a trabajar con la gente
aprendiendo cómo se prepara una
expedición la alimentación la carga la
construcción los instrumentos
científicos cómo se embalan para que nos
lleguen a talant activas
la cual preparamos bien la expedición de
100 mil 90 verano
se fue
y a medida del año 1990 yo le digo a mi
jefe del segundo abordo vieron el
capitán de navío su director y oficios
verde el personal
qué eligió
yo quiero ir a la antártica
creo que usted me ha visto como yo
trabajo 24 años
y quiero que quiero demostrarle que
lloró desarmar a usted me miró me dijo
sabes
que te voy a enviar a la antártica
pero para eso tenemos que preparar que
mandata aceptó unos cursos exámenes ahí
vemos si vas
elegí muchas gracias lo felicito pero yo
nunca lo voy a estar mal
me di la vuelta y se espera esté bien
parada
él siguió te envió a la antártica
dice usted tú te manda
un cóndor
eso significa que nunca más estando yo
vivo para seguir antártica porque mi
prestigio como su director
señor eligió no la carnal
yo con medio de septiembre del 90
me mandaron hacia los cursos de
incendios y de patrón de bote
a la escuela ingeniería naval de la
armada las salinas pero me mandaron con
la dotación antártica el ejército la
aviación y la armada yo era el más joven
como de ciento y tanto
y lo bueno que el curso incendio aprendí
mucho
como se se apagó un incendio en realidad
y vivir la realidad
comenzaba con incendios de un buque
lo aprendí me hicieron la prueba un 7
y ellos reales
la semana siguiente hice un curso de
bote
la cual fue duro porque yo no que anda
un bote zodiac
de mandar a un pueblo del ejército me
dieran al agua que un día me da vuelta
en bote tenía que saber reaccionar con
el bote y aprendí
llegó contento de la luna el ego jefe
aquí está mi nota 17 momento es
ahora de facto el examen médico
qué lo hacemos noviembre
y hacer el examen médico
la cual salieron todos bien
y yo a mi familia he tenido una sorpresa
yo dije que hacer los cursos para
aprender pero no ella dice que lleva la
antártica
entonces lo que sabes que es los cursos
niñas
salí bien mis el examen médico se lee
bien
creo que estoy apto mariana en cerveza
y el médico lo revisa uno hacer exámenes
salí bien y un problema apto para ir a
territorio antártico chileno
puentealtino de corazón de los buenos
voy contento
contento representando así las
expediciones
faltando 24 horas para ir a venir a la
antártica naviseer guardia me dice
cuánto te necesita sur estos a la
oficina aquí de paso su corriente
señor aquí estoy y frank jefe
administrativo que estoy a su director
igual me dice no hay gran táctica
pero por qué no en antártida
porque nos das mira como el error
de entusiasmar te hiciste bien todos los
cursos pero es muy joven
tenemos que conocer temas conocerte cómo
trabajas tú como logístico cómo
compartes con la gente cómo te comportas
con la gente
7 atento
señor eligió pero yo no lo dejan más los
mismos lo siento
estamos hablando del 91
y bueno
no pero
me dio ganas de renunciar al instituto
dijo esto no es para mí me esfuerce
mucho y creo que como este el joven
no voy a lograr
y se esfuerza dije mi señor es que las
plantas que van dijo 92 de mando
y buen oído
con la expedición
iba activa rumbo a puntarenas en avión
porque está esperando aquí en puntarenas
buscar más mi calle
y partimos
partimos vertimos bueno esto
91 92 93 94 fueron activos y el 95
vienen los jefes me llaman a una reunión
mi semilla juan ya que dólares yo
también voy a participar
que nunca es un chile
- la ciencia que yo sepa vas a
participar en la persecución de citación
con el doctor anhelo aguayo que una
eminencia el corte a mí
llegó el momento
para mí era difícil es seguir la mañana
sacarle muestra
bueno me explicaron que si una reunión
yo calmadamente
siguiendo las instrucciones
y llegó un momento que estamos la
antártica
repartiendo los proyectos y el momento
de los tiempos libres y vamos a ver las
mañanas
y me dice el jefe sanjuán me dice
yo confío en ti
pero tú hay con gente joven que son
investigadores científicos y un acuerdo
del jorge acevedo
en la persona que da el poder
y en media diciendo digamos primera es
que hacia la vega
mejor yo confío en ti juan que salga
bien ojalá que no pase nada
llegamos un lugar y es que la mañana
llegamos las 5 de la mañana
un lugar donde está sexto el ballenero
en la táctica
el agua casi la persecución
llegamos lugar y están nerviosos a
dormir toda la noche delante a las
cuatro de la mañana nervioso porque no
me esperaba a lo que iba
y de repente ya bajamos polvo de fuimos
yo lo igual comandante del google gozaré
por favor dejen un bote de emergencia
por si acaso las cosas la vida
y yo manejaba un bote zodiac grande
tenía buena visión y siempre parado
entonces iba viendo todos los lugares
los recovecos
y seguimos ballenas había como 20
ballenas habían barcos los cruceros
montones de sodio llegamos nosotros y
los botes de ellos empezaron a aguardar
porque lo vieron nosotros como un
respeto con un espía alojaron el área
nosotros solo solo solo solo para seguir
mañana habían como 20
y trabajamos como 9 horas
llegando a las muestras que significa
sacar la muestra la persona jorge en la
playa puede y hoy ha parado y el bote
así y teníamos que hacerle puntería la
ballena
y sacar la aleta dorsal 1 primero le
saca la foto a la cola para ver la cola
para registrarla y de repente esa suma
no le da dorsal
de frente de la mañana y una silla por
el costado izquierdo por el costado
derecho y siempre mirando a la ballena
uno adelante y siempre adelante y atrás
y yo me ocurría para atrás
messi lleva al lado yo me corría para el
otro lado hasta que la hacíamos puntería
le disparaba pero que le disparaba un
dardo pero no hacía daño le sacaba una
muestra para de la genética la ballena y
se guardaba desde una probeta éramos
como siete funcionar tendrá agua y cada
cual cumple una función sacan fotos
firmaban la ballena
digámoslo mejor ya buscar la muestra la
sana y si llego las ballenas le sacaron
fotos
de nuevo sucesivamente
les hagamos lograr a todas las ballenas
pero falta una pareja
de ballena
se me fue difícil
porque hay un momento que es el motor
tanto
8 horas de un problema en el motor de
sodio
y dije hasta aquí nos llegamos porque ya
se echó a perder no me hicieron
tengo que darle a los que 'no pero como
eso dijo bloqueando terminemos porque
así el proyecto a ser bueno para
nosotros y estos años voy a venir
ya huele el bueno el bus que siempre los
respaldos nosotros una distancia de 100
metros siempre ya la cuadra nosotros por
caso cualquier cosa
y lo fuimos remando
algo que
y los cambiamos en bote zodiac que mide
3 metros
éramos 8 personas
la cual que yo tenía que ir sentado no
tenía visión yo iba a ser el cotejo
y ahí a tomar tiempo fijo
y de repente
pa negre
que soy el único chileno creo que ahora
o río una ballena jorobada
y más
[Aplausos]
a quienes ustedes que la mañana mide 16
metros y mi bote mide 3 metros
que lo que hice yo bueno susto de los
mejores
lo levanta la cola los lanza todo el
bote es completamente
y cayó al agua todo el día el cuate y yo
miro para atrás a las ballenas pero que
lo que pasaba yo pensé que la otra
ballena no hizo colegas o tan fuerte
personas que luego los otros espacios
pero que el paso no levanto
ahí quedamos me aleje un poco reaccione
bien y la mina se hundió
se sumergió pero la otra mirando
salió a saber lógico que estaba pasando
bueno imagínense los garabatos que sean
árboles
el buque micardis llamada por radio por
suerte siempre ando con la radio aquí en
mi corazón
sin radio uno no puede navegar
y me llaman de lo que pasa es que
estamos todos bien joven al estilo work
y vamos a ver qué pasa
buenos días me consultó ver enojado
porque siempre dije que no podía hacer
una faena porque es muy peligroso andar
un bote chico en la que uno puede dar
vueltas
llegaba el buque
y lo primero que pregunta y le pasa algo
en la mañana
y yo lo miro y digo yo que no pregunta
cómo estamos nosotros primero
gracias dios no me pasó nada al sedación
ni a nosotros porque se me queda una
persona al agua saben que yo me voy
preso
terminé mi carrera y hay que hacer
pero sabes lo que quiero transmitir lo
importante que esto no pasó nada todos
contentos de la noche celebraron que no
pasó nada pero cura con pura bebida
yo no todo
porque no puede tomar un cachondeo
es como andar con en un auto
hasta la responsabilidad para uno
lo que quiero transmitir es muy
importante algo
son tres puntos importantes
el ser humano
el ser humano como yo como todos ustedes
tiene que cuidar la antártida
segundo
tiene que respetar la antártica
tercero uno nunca termina de aprender
porque le digo eso
una delante de las familias prácticas
muy grandes uno aprende mucho de cada
investigador científico
yo conozco personas que tienen 17 años
quedan en cuarto medio para es un
biólogo marino me dicen se acuerda de mí
sí sí me acuerdo que yo era el 1 biólogo
y esos bonitos a medir
la antártica es que cuidarla
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y